make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and we are getting back into
marvel zombies resurrection
yes we are on issue number two now uh
before we start this video
myself and mariah are going to be live
streaming on twitch.tv
codes at 6 30 p.m tonight which is
october october 1st thursday this is
thursday uh we're gonna be live
streaming at 6 30 p.m we're gonna be
playing fall guys and we're gonna be
doing drinking games so basically we're
gonna get drunk over the course of our
stream
so uh make sure you guys come out and
hang out with us while we just kind of
get progressively
less sober but what we end up doing here
is we kind of pick up
before the events of the main story
taking place right we basically get a
bit of a flashback here
and the idea is that when the initial
outbreak first happened peter parker is
spider-man and so on and so forth he's
immediately attacked by
basically the fantastic four reed
richards ben grimm johnny storm and
susan storm and they end up kind of
grabbing franklin and valeria and the
whole reason behind this is that where
they arrive here of course it's their
kids and they kind of say that like in
our previous life they were our family
but we have a new family now and these
kids are going to join us in this new
family and so you basically end up
having peter of course begging for them
you know begging for the fantastic four
to leave the kids alone
but ultimately susan storm ends up
biting franklin richards and so what
this points to is the idea that franklin
is infected right that's
basically what it looks like it's it's
kind of nuts here one of the other big
questions that sort of has to be asked
is why franklin richard's hair is dark
at this point in time and now it's
blonde we can kind of assume that it was
basically dyed and he's gone back to his
natural hair color you know over this
this time period but you end up
basically having this this scenario
where you kind of wake up with peter in
the present moment and they're basically
heading towards the phalanx wall now the
explanation of this
is essentially given to us by blade and
let's be honest with ourselves the only
reason blade's in this story is because
of the fact that he's getting a movie
if it wasn't for that we probably
wouldn't see him in here which may be
one of the reasons why it took so long
for the story to come out is that once
blade was announced for the mcu
marvel basically had to go back and just
rewrite the whole story to put blade in
it but the idea is that blade basically
says
that initially what humanity did is they
created machines right robots you know
artificial intelligence organisms they
were kind of created by a coalition
between shield and advanced idea
mechanics to fight the dead when they
first showed up here
because machines cannot be consumed by
the virus but what ended up happening is
that despite their best efforts the
various you know marvel zombies ended up
pushing humanity to the brink of almost
near extinction and so because there
aren't really any more humans running
the show here the machines have kind of
become their own
self-governing entity their own
self-governing society and they
basically fight against the zombies to
control the world it's really what what
you know kind of a subplot that seems to
be going on here and so when the
question's asked why blades even part of
this in the first place he's like
because i just killed the undead right i
don't really
care about you or franklin or valeria or
anything like that you guys are a means
to an end right you guys can help me get
from one location to the next but
understand if you die it's
not the biggest thing to me but while
they're traveling they're suddenly set
upon by marvel zombies right like the
eradicator from alpha flight and i'd
like to point out here this is probably
the most useful alpha flight's ever been
in the history of their publications
when they're zombies and they attack
like peter parker and everybody else and
they do what alpha flight does which is
die uh so these guys are basically
destroyed
because alpha flight sucks and uh and
this this basically leads to them of
course kind of crashing down
so on and so forth and immediately set
upon by like a whole host of zombies but
in the middle of all this
they're met by the arrival of a nimrod
right like a nimrod
sentinel now here's the funny thing
about this and something that i'm not
overly fond of here
this nimrod sentinel is basically just
an agent of the machine coalition right
the machine group right these these
robots that are kind of
out here nimrod here's here's an
important thing to understand with why i
view this right long before hickman
started writing x-men
nimrod has historically been kind of
like the one-two punch of the sentinel
program
there he came from days of future past
right in days of future past the machine
or the the sentinel program was jump
started after the assassination of
senators robert or senator robert kelly
and charles xavier of the x-men and
maura mctaggart but the sentinels ended
up coming to the realization
that if humanity tasked them with
tracking down and
eliminating mutants that much like what
you saw in x-men the animated series
that mutants are the next level of human
evolution and at their base level
mutants are human and so in turn they
turned on the entirety of humanity but
in their in the in the process of doing
that the sentinels were constantly
trying to find a way to better
themselves and the the you know this
this basically kind of coalesced in the
creation of the nimrod sentinel that had
the ability to like analyze a mutant
understand their powers and basically
find find ways to counter those powers
and so it was really just like a
super powerful being right here he's
just a guy that's there and is attacking
the various
marvel zombies now but you basically end
up having nana the sentinel who kind of
attacks the marvel zombies and it's
really just kind of you know these
robots
sort of locking everybody down right
like the other part of the other thing
that kind of comes out of this is you've
got viv
the daughter of vision who's kind of
running you know seems to be the one
running this show you've got a doombot
but you've also got frank castle who's
basically a robot as well and we get
this sort of explanation you know once
they're all taken
and they start talking to viv that one
viv isn't really who she used to be
right she's not as kind of outgoing and
and great as she used to be instead you
know her components have kind of been
replaced over the years and so while she
hasn't totally lost herself she's really
more enveloped in the realm of being a
machine than she is
being more human right so she's kind of
to a degree lost that human element
vivian is socially awkward
it's essentially what's kind of going on
here the other part of this is that the
last time valeria saw vivian it was
actually her and miles morales who were
traveling to an outbreak zone right in
hell's kitchen but miles morales didn't
survive
and that was kind of what led to vivian
sort of losing her humanity was looking
around and realizing how many people she
cared about were being killed off and
that their strength in being a robot
that can't really be converted the other
thing that has gone on here is that with
frank castle the reason why he looks the
way he does
is that being human being organic makes
you susceptible to the virus and so he
had willingly
undergone exposure to the transmode
virus which basically has converted him
into a cybernetic organism and so
essentially he's really more machine
than man
twisted and evil an agent of the dark
side now
[Laughter]
but that's basically what he is he's
basically kind of a walking talking
cyborg you know and he chose that path
and so while they're all kind of taken
to what they believe to be
is going to be you know more or less a
safe haven they end up finding out
they're being taken to a location
where the transmog virus is going to run
its course and they're going to be
converted into a machine now initially
there's there's an attempt by valeria to
appeal to
vivian but vivian doesn't really hear it
she's like you know we're going to make
you stronger right we're going to make
you better we're going to basically get
rid of any toxicity you have in your
system and
then we're going to then we're going to
fix you right we're going to turn you
into what basically what frank castle is
the other thing and it's really kind of
an easy thing to notice here the other
thing
is they talk about franklin right they
say what about the boy he's unaware of
his nature right but he would be a great
value against the respawn and this is
kind of important here
because it looks like franklin's powers
are more or less gone but what this
seems to point at is that his powers are
not gone that his powers are very much
intact and this would easily explain why
it is that while being attacked here
that he's not somebody who turned right
he didn't turn into one of the zombies
that he's still very much alive
and so from there you kind of have this
discussion about the nature of the
of these these respawn like these marvel
zombies and what we kind of get here is
this full-on explanation of what they
are
the funny thing is that in the main
marvel zombies story that was written by
robert kirkman back in the day that
until you got to the
the tie-in involving the evil dead there
wasn't really any explanation of how the
marvel zombies
worked outside of their zombies and
that's basically it right it was a dark
humor story and you just kind of went on
existing knowledge about zombies and
went forward from there right it wasn't
really a comic that was meant to be
taken super seriously with this one it
looks like marvel's kind of following
the standard fear of like offering an
explanation
and basically saying that it's not
really them being
undead in the traditional sense that
what it is is it's a kind of
sub-microbial parasitic organism that
shares a collective consciousness and
that when a person is bitten or infected
they're infected with this microbial
organism and that basically kills the
body and then in turn
kind of takes it over and brings it into
part of the hive mind and so she
basically says like there is no cure
here and it doesn't necessarily
seem to be true right if the microbial
organism kills the body then i guess
yes there is no cure in so far as those
individuals who have been
infected can actually be saved uh
instead you'd have to kill the microbial
organism which in turn means the body
would just shut back down again
right so that would basically be it so
it's like killing the brain and just
nothing else can follow right the body
just can't function after that
so so there is no cure in so far as like
hey we can save everybody out there and
make them back the way they were but
there is a cure
in the sense that you can kill the
organism and basically wipe out all the
zombies the problem with this is that
there's this massive explosion there
massive you know booming that kind of
takes place
outside the building and it's kind of
like you know like what is that right
like that felt close you know can
something actually bring this down and
the
the response of vivian is like nothing
out there can bring this down
short of any attack from like a hulk and
that's exactly what it is it's not just
a hulk
it's the hulk family man it's the
incredible hulk it's she-hulk it is
uh scar the son of the hulk and it's the
red hulk on top of that it's been grim
the thing
it's gladiator and hyperion like it's
the big heavy hitters of like the marvel
universe coming down here to just
rain down hell fire death and
destruction right it's
judgment day in this facility because
literally they just start ripping all
the robots to pieces right just like
tearing all these guys apart and so at
that point vivian's just like
run that's all we can do here is just
run that's the best we can do it's just
free for our lives right like just get
out of here as fast as we can the other
part of this is at the nana sentinel
vivian basically says that they were
essentially running a program running a
subroutine that would kind of
cleanse her programming as it was done
by peter parker and then kind of turn
her back into the way she is
or the way she's supposed to be as far
as like an agent of the of the machine
group the problem is that the program
hasn't really had a chance to run its
course and so she's kind of
stuck in that space in between and so
you end up basically having nana showing
up and kind of saving the day to a
degree and basically grabbing you know
everybody jumping on board and then her
flying off the problem with this
is that the incredible hulk jumps after
them and as you guys know the incredible
hulk can jump
fast and far because of his leg strength
right because of just the over
overwhelming amount of strength he has
and vivian asked the question of peter
parker why are you really going after
galactus right like what's the point of
this and peter initially responds and
saying like i told you it's because of
the kids and she says no
why are you going right like why are you
doing this why are you bringing the kids
there and peter says because he wants to
believe in something again
peter feels hopeless he feels hopeless
on all of this he feels hopeless because
you know he's the reason franklin got
infected he feels hopeless because the
entire superhuman
superhero community fell and there was
nothing he could really do but i would
say there's a bigger guilt going on here
than that
i would say that there came a point in
this battle when peter realized he
couldn't win
and fled fear got the better of him and
he ran away and left people to die right
i would say that's probably what really
happened here but with vivian getting
that response from peter she basically
says fine then like do whatever you need
to do
find something to believe in and she
sacrifices herself to the incredible
hulk right she goes to attack him and
basically knock him to the ground
vivian as we know is probably going to
die and so what you end up getting here
is it looks like this moment when peter
kind of seems to entertain this idea
of reactivating franklin's powers right
of like turning franklin's powers back
on we're not really given a definitive
explanation if that's the case
but you end up having you know valeria
who's kind of using this this radiation
detector to locate
galactus signal and starts to realize
like we're getting closer as they're
flying and what it seems like is they're
out in the middle of nowhere right
they're literally out in the middle of
the ocean and when the question is asked
by peter like it doesn't really make any
sense like we're out here in the middle
of nowhere the galactus hive always went
for population centers why would we be
here
the response to valeria is can you not
think of a population center in the
atlantic ocean
and she's like we're headed for the
atlantis colony we're headed for what
would be the kingdom of namor the
submariner with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like
and i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you